SEAN HANNITY, LIVE FROM
NEW YORK CITY, RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: TUCKER, THANK YOU.
GREAT SHOW AS ALWAYS.
IN THIS HOUR PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL DELIVER A PRIME TIME
ADDRESSED TO ALL AMERICANS
SPEAKING ABOUT THE CRISIS AT OUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
A PARTIAL GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN IS
STILL IN EFFECT AS DEMOCRATS
BURY THEIR HEADS IN THE SAND,
CLOSE THEIR EYES AND PRETEND
THAT AMERICA'S BORDERS ARE
TOTALLY SAFE AND SECURE.
THEY ARE NOT.
DEMOCRATS ARE ADAMANTLY REFUSING
TO GIVE BORDER PATROL AGENTS THE
TOOLS THEY DESPERATELY NEED, AND
ARE ASKING FOR.
THAT IS A STRATEGIC WALL ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, BUT EVEN ONE
TOP DEMOCRAT TONIGHT ADMITTING
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES IN
FACT HAVE THE POWER TO BUILD A
WALL WITHOUT ANY CONGRESSIONAL
APPROVAL WHATSOEVER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DOES PRESIDENT TRUMP HAVE THE
ABILITY OR THE AUTHORITY TO
DECLARE A NATIONAL EMERGENCY TO
HAVE THE MILITARY BUILD HAS A
WALL?
>> UNFORTUNATELY THE SHORT
ANSWER IS YES.
THERE'S A PROVISION IN LAW THAT
SAYS THE PRESIDENT CAN DECLARE
AN EMERGENCY.
PRIMARILY IT'S BEEN DONE TO
BUILD FACILITIES IN AFGHANISTAN
AND IRAQ.
IN THIS CASE I THINK THE
PRESIDENT WOULD BE WIDE OPEN TO
A COURT CHALLENGE SAYING, WHERE
IS THE EMERGENCY?
>> Sean: WHERE IS THE
EMERGENCY?
WE WILL ANSWER THAT QUESTION.
PAY ATTENTION TO THE FOLLOWING
STATISTICS, THAT OF COURSE THE
HEAT TRUMP DEMOCRATS ARE NOT
TELLING YOU.
IN THE PAST TWO YEARS ALONE,
CRIMINAL ALIENS HAVE BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR APPROXIMATELY,
LOOK AT THIS NUMBER -- 235,000
VIOLATION OR LESS OF THE LAW,
INCLUDING 4,000 HOMICIDES,
30,000 SEX CRIMES AND OVER
100,000 VIOLENT ASSAULTS.
IN 2018, 17,000 INDIVIDUALS WITH
CRIMINAL RECORDS WERE
APPREHENDED AT THE BORDER AND
THE CRISIS GOES MUCH, MUCH
DEEPER.
IN TOWNS AND CITIES ALL ACROSS
THE COUNTRY, WE KNOW ABOUT THE
OPIOID CRISIS.
300 AMERICANS ARE KILLED EVERY
SINGLE WEEK FROM HEROIN.
90% OF THAT HEROIN IS FLOODING
ACROSS OUR SOUTHERN BORDER, AND
THAT DEATH TOLL BY THE WAY IS
EQUAL -- THINK ABOUT THIS -- TO
THE NUMBER OF AMERICAN TROOPS
KILLED EVERY WEEK IN VIETNAM
DURING THE YEAR 1968, THE WAR'S
DEADLIEST YEAR.
OVER A TEN-YEAR PERIOD, TOTAL
AMERICANS KILLED FROM ILLEGAL
DRUGS COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER WILL BE NEARLY THREE
TIMES HIGHER THAN THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF U.S. TROOPS KILLED IN
VIETNAM.
THERE IS YOUR CRISIS, BY ANY
DEFINITION.
BUT DON'T EXPECT TO SEE THIS ON
ANY OTHER NETWORK.
OF COURSE, DONALD TRUMP WANTS
SOMETHING AND THEY ARE JUST
AGAINST IT.
INSTEAD OF REPORTING FACTS AND
TRUTHS, THEY SEEM CONTENT JUST
TRASHING TRUMP VOTERS.
OVER ON CNN, RICK WILSON FIRST
TRASHED TRUMP SAYING FIRST WE
DIDN'T HAVE TEETH, AND NOW HE'S
SAYING WE ARE NOT SOPHISTICATED
ENOUGH OR SMART ENOUGH TO
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE INVOLVING
BORDER SECURITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA OF A PHYSICAL WALL,
DONALD TRUMP LOVE SELLING THIS
TO HIS BASE AND AGAIN, THESE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
SOPHISTICATED, THEY ARE NOT
BRIGHT.
THEY KNEW NOT UNDERSTAND THE
COMPLEXITY -- >> HERE WE GO WITH
CONDESCENDING TO US -- THAT'S
WHY WE WANT OUR WALL.
>> DONALD TRUMP'S TARGET
AUDIENCE, HE'S A CON MAN WHO
WORKS ON SOPHISTICATED PEOPLE
VERY SUCCESSFULLY.
>> Sean: AND WHILE FAKE NEWS
CNN INSULT OUR INTELLIGENCE,
THEY ARE REFERRING TO AMERICANS.
WE THE PEOPLE, AS COWARDS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE CONCERN OF A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS IS THEY CAN SEE THE
TRUMP DRIVING OFF THE CLIFF BUT
THEY LOOK AT THE SHORT-TERM AND
THEY FEAR NOT THE GENERAL
ELECTION IN 2020 BUT THEY FEAR
THE POTENTIAL THAT TRUMP BACKED
CANDIDATE COULD PRIMARY THEM AND
BEAT THEM EVEN BEFORE THEY GOT
TO NOVEMBER.
IS THAT FEAR, COWARDICE OR
STUPIDITY?
IT'S ALL OF THOSE THINGS BUT, IT
HAS BEEN IN REPUBLICAN POLITICS
FOR THE LAST YEAR.
>> Sean: REMEMBER I WAS
TALKING ABOUT, WE HAD THE HATE
TRUMP DEMOCRATS AND THE HATE
TRUMP MEDIA, AND I WENT INTO
GREAT DETAIL?
PERSONAL ATTACKS WHATEVER STOP
THE SHOW FROM REPORTING TRUTHS.
AND FOR US AND MOST AMERICANS,
THIS IS NOT A POLITICAL GAME.
WE ARE SEEING THIS IS ABOUT LIFE
AND DEATH.
THIS IS ABOUT INNOCENT, BRAVE,
LAW-ABIDING AMERICANS AND LEGAL
IMMIGRANTS DYING BECAUSE OUR
BORDERS ARE NOT SECURE.
WE KNOW THE THE STORY OF RONIL
SINGH, HE WAS GUNNED DOWN AND
PUT TO REST THIS WEEKEND.
HIS 5-MONTH-OLD SON WILL NEVER
KNOW HIS FATHER.
THAT'S LIFE AND DEATH.
THE PERSON RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT
HEINOUS ATTACK HAD A CRIMINAL
RECORD.
BUT IN CALIFORNIA THEY HAVE
SINKS HAVE CENTURY CITIES BUT
THE WHOLE STATE AS A SANCTUARY
STATE AND THOSE POLICIES
PREVENTED THAT FROM HAPPENING.
GOVERNMENT POLICIES ARE NOW
LITERALLY AIDING AND ABETTING
LAWBREAKING AND PAVING THE WAY
FOR FUTURE CRIMES.
WHY DO YOU THINK THE GOVERNMENT
WOULD ACT AND AID AND ABET
CRIMINALS?
YOU HAVE JERRY BROWN VEERING HIS
HEAD IN THE SAND BUT REALLY, HE
OUGHT TO BE TAKING
RESPONSIBILITY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE COUNTY SHERIFF HAS COME
OUT PRETTY CRITICAL OF THE
POLICIES THAT YOU SIGNED INTO
LAW IN 2017.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THAT
CRITICISM?
AND DO YOU THINK PERHAPS A SIDE
EFFECT OF THOSE LAWS IS THAT
MORE BAD ACTORS MIGHT FALL
THROUGH THE CRACKS?
>> NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
HE WAS ARRESTED AND BROUGHT INTO
JAIL EVEN BEFORE THE SANCTUARY
LAW WAS ENACTED.
SO I.C.E., THE IMMIGRATION
PEOPLE COULD HAVE GONE OUT AND
GOTTEN HIM.
THE POLICE OR THE SHERIFF COULD
HAVE TOLD THE IMMIGRATION
SERVICE.
I THINK PEOPLE NOW ARE LOOKING
TO BLAME SOMEBODY, BECAUSE OF
THE TERRIBLE THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED, BUT IT HAD NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE LAW IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Sean: SANCTUARY STATES
LITERALLY PREVENT CRIMINALS THAT
WOULD NORMALLY HAVE BEEN HANDED
OVER TO I.C.E., THAT MAKES IT
ILLEGAL.
THAT MEANS THEY GO FREE.
WHAT HAPPENS IS ALL TOO COMMON
OF AN OCCURRENCE.
NO HAVE YOU HEARD THE NAME OF
PIERCE CORCORAN?
ON DECEMBER 29, HE WAS KILLED BY
A SUSPECTED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
DRIVING WITHOUT A LICENSE,
WITHOUT INSURANCE AND ON THE
WRONG SIDE OF THE HIGHWAY.
PIERCE WAS ONLY 22 YEARS OLD.
TONIGHT ON THIS SHOW HIS PARENTS
WILL JOIN US RIGHT AFTER THE
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
PUBLIC NEED TO START ASKING SOME
REALLY IMPORTANT TOUGH QUESTION
QUESTIONS.
HOW MANY OF OUR FELLOW CITIZENS
HAVE BEEN MURDERED BECAUSE OF
UNSECURED BORDERS?
IF THAT'S NOT A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY, I DON'T KNOW HOW HE
WOULD EVER DEFINE ONE.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS EMERGENCY
IS TAKING PLACE ON BOTH SIDES OF
THE BORDER.
60,000 IN ADMISSIBLE OR ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE TURNED AWAY FROM
OUR BORDERS EVERY SINGLE MONTH.
A RECORD NUMBER OF MIGRANTS ARE
OVERWHELMING AMERICAN DETENTION
FACILITIES CAUSING THEM TO BE
DANGEROUSLY OVERCROWDED AND ONE
OUT OF EVERY THREE MIGRANT
WOMEN, THOSE WHO TRY TO MAKE THE
TRIP TO OUR SOUTHERN BORDER
SADLY, TRAGICALLY, EVIL OCCURS
AND THEY ARE ASSAULTED SEXUALLY.
LAST MONTH ALONE, 20,000
CHILDREN WERE SMUGGLED OR
TRAFFIC RIGHT HERE INTO THE
UNITED STATES AND THOUSANDS MORE
HAVE DIED ON THAT ARDUOUS,
DIFFICULT, HARD JOURNEY ACROSS
THE BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS LONG WARNED
ABOUT THIS INCREDIBLY SERIOUS
SITUATION BUT, WHAT WAS
NANCY PELOSI'S REACTION TO
DEVASTATING FACTS?
ACCORDING TO THE FOX NEWS DURING
A BRIEFING, SHE SAID I REJECT
YOUR FACTS.
TO WHICH NIELSEN RESPONDED
"THESE ARE NOT MY FACTS, THESE
ARE THE FACTS.
SO THIS WEEKEND THE
VICE PRESIDENT PANTS,
NANCY PELOSI AND CHUCK SCHUMER,
THEY DIDN'T BOTHER TO SHOW UP
FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT.
INSTEAD, NANCY AND CHUCK, THEY
WERE TOO BUSY.
THEY CENSOR AIDS TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THAT'S HOW SERIOUSLY THEY ARE
TAKING WHAT IS NOW A DEADLY
ISSUE.
AND ARROGANTLY OFFERING, WE WILL
GIVE YOU A DOLLAR FOR THE BORDER
WALL.
IF THAT'S THEIR ATTITUDE, WILL
SHE OFFER THE FAMILIES LOST
LOVED ONES ANY FINANCIAL
COMPENSATION?
IS THAT HOW WE NOW DEFINE
COMPASSION AND THAT LIBERALISM?
WHAT DOES SHE HAVE TO SAY TO ALL
THE ANGEL MOM'S ANGEL DADS AND
KIDS?
WHAT WILL SHE SAY WHEN OFFICER
RONIL SINGH'S SON IS 18 YEARS
OLD OR GOING INTO COLLEGE?
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE 98% OF
PEOPLE THAT WANT A BETTER LIFE,
BECAUSE THEY COME FROM COUNTRIES
OF POVERTY AND WANT OPPORTUNITY
AND FREEDOM THAT WE ALL TAKE FOR
GRANTED.
WE ARE NOT WORRIED ABOUT THEM.
WE ARE JUST ASKING THAT THEY
COME LEGALLY.
IT'S ABOUT THE 2%, THOSE THAT
ARE COMMITTING CRIMES, HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND DRUG
TRAFFICKING, VIOLENT OFFENDERS.
EVEN THE THOUSANDS OF GOOD
HONEST IMMIGRANTS COMING ACROSS
OUR BORDER BECAUSE THEY DO WANT
A BETTER LIFE ARE TRAFFIC TO
THEMSELVES.
ASSAULTS ARE HAPPENING, EVEN
PEOPLE KILLED DURING THAT
DANGEROUS TRACK.
THIS IS A NATIONAL EMERGENCY AND
IT'S TIME TO BUILD THE WALL.
THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT TO FIGHT
TO PROTECT AMERICAN LIVES.
BUT HOW DO YOU NEGOTIATE WITH
PEOPLE?
THEY WON'T EVEN SIT DOWN, THEY
SEND THEIR AIDES TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE VICE PRESIDENT.
PEOPLE WHO WON'T EVEN RECOGNIZE
THAT THE PROBLEM THAT EXISTS.
PEOPLE WHO REJECT TRUTH AND
SIMPLE FACTS AND CARE MORE ABOUT
POLITICAL OPTICS THAN THE LIVES
AND THE WELL-BEING OF AMERICANS.
WHILE DEMOCRATS TRY THEIR BEST
TO IGNORE VERY REAL, SERIOUS
CRISES, CONTINUE TO OBSESS ABOUT
ONE OF THEIR FAVORITE FANTASIES.
ALL THEY WANT TO TALK ABOUT,
DONALD TRUMP, IMPEACHMENT.
WHICH WEEKS LATE LAST WEEK ISN'T
GOING TO HAPPEN.
NOW, ALL THEY WILL DO IS
DISTRACT AND DIVIDE THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE AND THEY WON'T BE SERVING
THEIR CONSTITUENTS.
ONE DAY AFTER BEING SWORN IN,
FRESHMAN DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN RASHIDA TO LEAD
WENT ON A VULGAR GRANT VOWING TO
IMPEACH THE MFER.
SHE SAID THAT TRUMP "MET HIS
MATCH."
RADICAL FAR LEFT, AND CONGRESS
IS OFF TO A GREAT START.
THE NEW RISING STAR, ALEXANDRIA
CORTEZ IO    OVERCARDS IO CORTEZ
CORTEZ IO    OVERCARDS IO CORTEI
CORTEZ IO    OVERCARDS IO CORTES
TRYING TO SELL AMERICA ON THIS
FAR LEFT, ARGUING THAT WE SHOULD
LET FACTS GET IN THE WAY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WHEN PEOPLE HEAR THE WORD
SOCIALISM, THEY THINK
SOVIET UNION, CUBA, VENEZUELA.
IS THAT WHAT YOU HAD IN MIND?
BECAUSE WHAT WE HAD IN MIND, AND
WHAT MY POLICIES MOST CLOSELY
RESEMBLE IS WHAT WE SEE IN THE
U.K., NORWAY AND FINLAND.
>> "THE WASHINGTON POST"
RECENTLY AWARDED YOU FOR
PERSONAL KILOS FOR SUPPORTING
STATISTICS WITH PENTAGON
SPENDING.
>> IF THEY REALLY WANT TO BLOW
UP ONE FIGURE HERE OR ONE THEY
ARE, I WOULD ARGUE THEY ARE
MISSING THE FOREST FOR THE
TREES.
THERE ARE LOTS OF PEOPLE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT BEING PRECISELY
AND SEMANTICALLY CORRECT THAN
ABOUT BEING MORALLY RIGHT.
>> Sean: IT'S ONLY A
$21 TRILLION MISTAKE, WHY YOU
PAY ATTENTION TO FACTS AND
FIGURES.
SO ASK YOURSELF, WHY IS SHE SO
AFRAID TO EXPLAIN HOW TO PAY FOR
IT?
SHE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES.
SHE'S ALREADY THROWN HER SUPPORT
BEHIND -- GET THIS, A 70% TAX
RATE FOR AMERICAN CITIZENS.
BUT REMEMBER, THE BOTTOM 50% OF
WAGE EARNERS PAY LESS THAN 3% OF
INCOME TAXES ALREADY.
AND BY THE WAY, KEEP IN MIND,
SHE WILL DEFINITELY NEED A LOT
MORE OF YOUR MONEY IF SHE WANTS
TO ACCOMPLISH THE RADICAL AGENDA
SO DON'T BE FOOLED.
PAY FOR MASSIVE ENTITLEMENTS
LIKE GOVERNMENT RUN HEALTH CARE,
GOVERNMENT MANDATED CLIMATE
SHAMING, GOVERNMENT FUNDED
COLLEGE FOR ALL.
IT WILL REQUIRE MASSIVE, HEAVY
TAXES ON ALL AMERICANS, NOT JUST
THEM MILLIONAIRES AND
BILLIONAIRES THAT ARE SO OFTEN
DEMONIZED.
INTERESTINGLY, EVEN THE     THEV
INTERESTINGLY, EVEN THE     THEE
INTERESTINGLY, EVEN THE     THE'
INTERESTINGLY, EVEN THE     THES
WHOOPI GOLDBERG HAD SOME WORDS.
>> I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO SIT
STILL FOR A MINUTE AND LEARN THE
JOB, BECAUSE THERE ARE PEOPLE IN
THAT PARTY WHO HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THEIR TAILS OFF FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
>> AND THEY KNOW A LOT.
THEY'VE BEEN AROUND.
>> AND YOU COULD LEARN SOME
STUFF.
BEFORE YOU START ON PEOPLE AND
WHAT THEY'VE DONE, YOU HAVE TO
DO SOMETHING, TOO.
>> Sean: AND BY THE WAY,
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ, YOU ARE WELCOME
ON THIS SHOW.
I'LL EVEN GIVE YOU THREE BONUS
HOURS ON MY RADIO SHOW.
BUT WE WON'T HOLD OUR BREATH.
OF COURSE, SHE TALKED ABOUT
DISGUSTING ATTACKS ON WHAT
ARE -- HE WAS HIT WITH A WAVE OF
EXTREMELY DISTURBING COMMENTS
FROM SUPPORTERS OF ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ DURING A TWITTER
EXCHANGE ON TAX REFORM.
NOW SOME ARE SENDING VIOLENT
MESSAGES ABOUT, REMEMBER, THE
ATTEMPTED ASSASSINATION OF A
G.O.P. CONGRESSMAN, AND IN 2017,
STEVE SCHOOLEY'S WAS AND NEARLY
DIED, AND THERE ARE SOME
COMMENTS THAT INCLUDE, KICK HIS
CANE AND, SNIPE HIS.
IT'S CLEARLY NOT PRODUCTIVE TO
ENGAGE HERE WITH SOME OF YOUR
RADICAL FOLLOWERS.
HASHTAG IS DECLASSE.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE WILL JOIN US
LATER IN THE SHOW.
OF COURSE, THIS IS ALL PART OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY'S HARD TURN
TO THE LEFT.
A LOT OF THIS NOW IS BASED ON
HATRED.
A LOT OF IT IS NO OBSESSION,
FIXATION, EVERY SECOND, EVERY
MINUTE, EVERY HOUR OF EVERY DAY.
ONE OF THE CHAMPIONS OF THE FAR
LEFT ELIZABETH WARREN IS SEEING
HER 2020 PRESIDENTIAL HOPES WITH
HER BEFORE HER EYES.
THAT IS NOW PRESSED ON OUR NOW
INFAMOUS DNA DEBACLE AND SHE HAS
NOW COME UP WITH A BRAND-NEW
EXCUSE FOR HER NATIVE AMERICAN
LIES, TELLING THE AUDIENCE
"TRIBAL CITIZENSHIP IS VERY
DIFFERENT FROM ANCESTRY."
SENATOR, JUST STOP WHILE YOU ARE
AHEAD AND ADMIT IT, YOU WERE
CAUGHT DECEIVING VOTERS.
YOU ARE EMPLOYERS AND YOUR
FRIENDS AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
NOW OUR OWN CONGRESSIONAL
COLLEAGUES SEEM TO BE TAKING
NOTICE.
NEW REPORT FROM POLITICO, THEY
ARE KEEPING THEIR DISTANCE AND
WITHHOLDING ANY ENDORSEMENTS,
ESPECIALLY AS A FORMER